[Music]  that needs to leave this game he's very  dangerous  you know I don't need the million  dollars I'm playing to win survivor  because I am gonna be the ultimate  survivor Ben's playing because he feels  this need to win this money for his  family which makes him ferocious  hopefully he doesn't find that [ __ ]  idol he's a long travel and now we get  to sleep so let's finish it  yes I'm you know I have no protection  now I have no alliance and I know  they're gunning for me the only thing  that can pull up their game is if I find  another it is absolutely crazy  nobody's follow me they're feeling too  comfortable I don't know why cuz they  might else to be played till 5:00 and so  as long as my heart is beating I'm  looking for an idol everybody's sleeping  everybody's aunt out cozy with their  blankets and pillows and I'm out here  for my family so dude no time for  sleeping arrest this is more than a game  you know this is a mission this is a job  [Music]